you and i have spoken about this before
how much credibility is there behind the
story of your dad with marilyn monroe
that that's out there a lot of people
have talked about that before
but how much of credibility is there
with the story of him and jackie he said
he partied with jackie in florida jackie
yo jackie kennedy jackie kennedy him and
jackie apparently used to hang out
together you know i will tell you this
my dad sometimes embellished things a
little bit yeah but he never straight
out lied to me so he might have made it
a little bit better than it really was
maybe
but when he told me something i believed
it you know the whole marilyn monroe
story i mean
when he finally told me that was after
my mom died because i said to him i said
dad
why did bobby kennedy come after you in
such a way what happened you know and he
said to me mike now that your mother has
passed i would never be disrespectful to
her i can tell you and he said he had an
affair with marilyn monroe and then this
might have been a little bit
embellishment he said marilyn monroe was
in bed with bobby kennedy and she
started yelling my name
wow
it was the swinging 60s baby wow and
then he said bobby got on the phone with
hoover and said get franzis no matter
what you got to do oh man and that's
when all the trouble started all he had
to do was run for another year or two he
would have been all right
but i mean i do know he was with her
because i said dad he said no i'm like
straight straight school what are your
thoughts on you know jfk bobby kennedy
even mlk because that's when you were a
kid and you're in your teens what was
that like in that time cia doing some
house cleaning bobby kennedy yeah i had
to dislike because my dad always said it
was him that went after him and put him
in all his trouble because remember
hoover you know up until that time never
would even admit that the mafia existed
and the reason for that is because one
of the reasons you know frank costello
was involved with the store club who
were used to going there quite a bit and
they had a lot of dirt on him
and we do cover this in mafia statesman
they had a lot of dirt on him and uh he
would never even admit to it until
velocity came around then he had to
admit to it but
but he never went after the mob
bobby kennedy gloves off he went after
him well uh
you guys if it's all right if i say you
and sammy both uh talked about the mob's
involvement in the jfk assassination as
well in this coming and you had said
that you two had never spoken you had
never talked about it before and you
corroborated each other's story and it
was almost the exact same story i heard
it all my life i mean why would people
lie to me about it you know from the
right people and what i what i believe
is the classified documents about the
kennedy killing will never be revealed
because the government will never want
the public to know
that the mafia got to a sitting
president that's my belief i don't think
they'll ever be unclassified trump tried
to or he was going to and then they put
a stop to it well biden just is
apparently going to declassify the 911
uh report as well so you have to adam's
point you have marilyn monroe dying in
very very uh
very
interesting circumstances
do you drug overdose yes but drug
overdose apparently after a phone call
to the white house
so
basically or something
well it's pretty well known that her and
jack kennedy and then jackson yeah
passed her off on her but on his brother
bobby uh because she called one night
and jackie answered the phone and it was
like a whole thing imagine that you're
the president united states and you
still got a landline there were no cell
phones back then man and you know
marilyn monroe is calling the white
house has the white house line and mrs
uh
this is first lady it's just a phone
number
growing up i had a poster of pamela
anderson on my wall it was a 16 year old
kid pamela anderson was marilyn monroe
like that girl for you no
okay i mean uh you know she died in the
60s i was still a kid okay but uh well
we'll get just to get back on it so just
real quick do you think
the kennedy's had marilyn monroe killed
you know rumors all the time but i never
heard anything from any of my associates
at the time that that was true and do
you think the mob had anything to do
with bobby as well as jack i never heard
that either really no
only jack really so what do you think
about sarhan sarhan you know it's all
over the news and they're going to let
them out yeah they're going to let them
out
you know listen you know from a guy
that's done time and look i've either
been in prison or visiting prison my
entire life this guy did a lot of time
if he's rehabilitated and they believe
he has let him out for those of you that
don't know the murderer of bobby kennedy
which is going out of jail and also for
people that don't know bobby kennedy was
a shoeing to be the president united
states yeah of course absolutely the
level of momentum he had was was
understood
and maybe even more qualified than his
brother oh definitely yeah yeah a lot of
people think his brother was the real
brains behind the operation but uh jack
just had that charisma and bobby was
what the attorney general
according to rudy uh when colombo did
the anti-italian italian anti-defamation
league that's that was the italian
american civil rights league that was
when the entire
fbi apparently was like all right enough
of this we gotta go get these guys well
i was one of the first ones called to go
on that line and that that thing started
just several months after my dad was
went to prison was that like the black
lives matter of its time was that like
yeah i mean we were a little bit more
respectful that we didn't start rioting
and looting and doing all of that well
you weren't commies no
we got a call to go down to 69th street
and third avenue and pick at the fbi
building
and when i got there i mean i was a kid
i was not 20 years old when i got there
um they handed me a sign
and the sign said my father was a victim
of fbi gestapo tactics he was framed and
sentenced to 50 years in prison that was
the sign i had to carry that's not
leaving a lot for interpretation no
and that line grew from you know i mean
40 50 people the first or second day to
thousands thousands within a short
period of time i mean joe colombo
rallied the troops no doubt and
everybody on the line all the maid guys
on the line were very upset they didn't
want to be there
they didn't want to be there you know it
got so bad the fbi were so upset they
were throwing water balloons down from
from you know fbi was throwing water
water balloons down on us on the line
yeah that's how crazy well according to
giuliani that was like the last draw
that was like the okay oh you guys you
guys want to do this okay yeah yeah and
that was not a popular move uh within
the mob circles for joe colombo so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you